[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whenever we run we have stacy here
and mike quiet mike why are you doing
the same thing i just did
hi guys tcd here i'm weirdo
stacy d and silent mike tell us about
your summer that's coming up we were
just talking about it
yeah so um i have a seminar coming up
it's sold out so i can't
yeah dude thank god um where it's here
in l.a so it's going to be here in la
it's ladies only
uh it's going to be a good time these
two will be there i'm going to do a
dudes only one
what if i identify as a lady uh then
you're welcome
okay cool yeah for sure you are i i've
gotten a couple of dudes that are like
can i come and i just think that i
haven't
made the step to make it feel welcoming
enough for everybody because it's like a
place for women to kind of talk about
their
vulnerabilities and stuff i don't want
to be there then it's okay
you have to be there as a knowledge
sounds boring man
a lot of feelings yeah what's the
seminar for i thought we're just gonna
work out girl
it's self-love and healing that's what
it's like an empowering oh
it's so it's working it's a bad [ __ ]
seminar yeah it's working out
no no working out you're coming dressed
up you're coming like glam the [ __ ] up
in your heels in a dress it's like
it's a day for ladies to like feel
themselves you know like to come
cute as [ __ ] i need one of those i don't
want to go to that i want to feel more
you weren't invited you wouldn't you
didn't get that
joe you want to have one just me and you
buddy yeah you guys can hang out on
saturday yeah we'll just play
outside i thought we were all going to
work out together
and empower each other through muscles
you still can do that yeah no
set it set the date when do you want to
do it no to your seminar
no that's not what my summer is about
okay we can have a seminar with you
though
that's what you want yeah and we'll make
it all about you joe all right it'll be
called
muscles muscles that's copyrighted build
your muscles
build your confidence yeah that's a good
one okay well back to you though
so i didn't know this because for some
reason i alm i
automatically thought your seminar was
gonna be about fitness
i think yeah a lot of people would think
that just because i grew up in like the
fitness world um but
i kind of try to get like stay away from
that a little bit because i don't want
to just be like a fitness person
it's the second year that we're doing
this and the first year was really
successful
and this year it's going to be even more
successful god willing how does this
start give me
just a sample like what i just started
talking about my feelings no i have a
lot of feelings no so basically i come
in yeah i'm real sensitive
i really am if you could sit there and
be quiet i would actually invite you oh
[ __ ]
he's out he's out that's not a bad [ __ ]
seminar if i can't be my own bad [ __ ]
self
you know abby just fit my little ball in
your little stacy's d
world and whatever you want me to be
i'll be that person i need to let
everybody know that mike and i get along
like this because they're going to come
for me for punking you so much
damn time they don't know the history
undiagnosed
hsp what the hell is that highly
sensitive person
[ __ ] self-diagnosed i can't be my bad
[ __ ] self when you guys always put me
down
okay she was in the middle of the day
explaining
shut up what's going on in the seminar
though you what
what happens it's it's talking it's like
interaction between the audience myself
and then at the end i do have a series
on youtube coming to the cheese man
which is more fun and then we're gonna
have that live
so michi's is like the michelada drink
and then cheese is gossip
and we're also dancing at the end that's
why i told everybody to bring chunk
can i show up just for that part um no
i think that you would be kind of um a
hit
so we'll save you for the next one you
might take all the attention away
is what you're saying okay so the reason
why you're
you're you're doing this is is for like
self-empowerment or like
self-empowerment but the empowerment of
everybody there
so it's called a self-love and healing i
think that women go through a lot
especially in relationships and they
lose value of who they are
as people because they become partners
and mothers before they become
themselves
because women are so giving they
definitely yeah yeah that's like my mom
she don't know who the [ __ ] she is yeah
she should come honestly we're capped
out but i'll make a groove
imagine she comes out with like sejjas
and like her nails done
yeah that's a bad beard he's like i know
who i am now
hola joey it's me mom
i'm like dad you've been chilling around
too many latinas
she speaks her mind she's like no joke
sit the [ __ ] down start snapping and
[ __ ]
her nails get longer and longer and
longer damn mom you're fierce
mom is that cardi b coming from your
room
that's basically what it is though it's
a day for women to feel like themselves
outside of what they have going on in
their
personal life in addition to that like
yeah that's the surface thing but i
think what you're really doing uh in
addition
is you're bringing a lot of girls
together when we're so used to
like being catty with each other i can't
[ __ ] get that dude i [ __ ] love
girls
jealous [ __ ] yes so the fact that a
bunch of girls that don't know each
other are coming together and like damn
you look good you look good
and now everyone is really safe space
it's like oh [ __ ] we can co-exist and
not
hate each other there's hella bad
[ __ ] and that's what i live by like
i've never been online and said like oh
she looks too good for me or like oh
like i'm not gonna hang out with her
because she looks prettier
[ __ ] no like i love bad [ __ ]
literally girls can't actually run [ __ ]
but they're too busy fighting each other
i just don't understand it i literally
have
girlfriends only girls do wrench it yeah
they do and then like population wise
there's
more women than men for unfortunately in
history men have done a really good job
of keeping women as second class
citizens you know why just because they
can beat us up
most of the time that's true just most
of the time not all the time
and then they kill you till they're off
too so yeah men aren't that smart really
you said that yeah i did i you know you
know what though i don't
i really don't like how recently though
it's been so divisive like in
everything and like guys team girls team
like everything is like the toxic
max masculinity and all that [ __ ] that's
going around it's exhausting
what about just teaming up everybody and
and being a family like
right i don't know it's just weird the
more ice group girls group and [ __ ] not
just even the sex thing it's like
literally
everything everything yeah the more
attention you bring to how different we
are the more you segregate yourself
rather than yeah just say like bro like
i mean we all joke but we're all like
really good friends when we start joking
about like who's latin who's asian or
whatever but like
they don't care yeah but like people are
dead serious with it they are
if you're just like no like i'm human
and you're also
human well i do have something to say
about that um i think we are
a group of open-minded people who
respect each other in and out of these
videos
but in the outside world not everybody
thinks like we for sure you know we live
in la so we're like very privileged to
have that mentality
that's true to treat each other as
equals but we
i and i'm sure you guys all have been
a part of a world that didn't treat you
as an equal because you're of different
ethnicity or because you're a woman
and this is why these groups and these
conversations and these topics are
brought up to light
or age or yeah everything
or class you can pretend you can sit
here and be like okay like
we're all the same you know when we're
not you know our experiences have made
us different
what i'm saying though is if we want to
move past it like the more the more we
put it into a microscope the more it's
going to be an issue
because you start to look at it you we
could come up with anything and you're
going to find a negative to it
too much coffee if we look deep enough
someone died from coffee yesterday right
but you're talking about coffee and
you're talking about like women's
and like minority issues uh and i think
the more we try
to bring a point up how we need to pay
more attention over here more pay
attention over here then you're just
bringing up the negative rather than
just focusing on how to
solve the issue i do see that right but
then we have to also recognize that
there is
an issue right for sure and then and
then people can can say oh you know what
the way i was feeling about that
was actually very valid but now how do i
move past that so
right now that's what she's saying that
we're at that stage where we accept that
yes this is an issue
let's start from this and now we can go
to to the phase where you're you want to
go to
yeah i just think most people spend time
talking about the issue rather than
talking about the the
song i agree politics and that's race
and that's sex and that's
because that's money dude that gives you
the ratings that if let's create some
drama for sure for sure
people love drama tabletop or kitchen
table conversations are the same way too
and maybe it is because all we're used
to is the media doing it and politics do
it for money i mean think about it in a
very
human level right how difficult is it to
have a relationship with someone
very how fast can you come up with a
solution like
not every no one knows everyone's just
working it out and i think that's the
same thing
with society it's a relationship
community is a relationship
right it's complicated people have
different goals ideals
values they take different sides you
know it's it's it's
it's the same thing but like i think if
you look at it on a regular level
where uh divorce is such a high rate
because people can't figure it out
people can't continue like they can't
resolve conflict is what i'm saying sure
it's [ __ ] difficult yeah so put it on
a global platform like is it going to be
even harder it might it might be near
impossible yeah it might be near
impossible right but
uh doesn't mean that it's difficult that
means we shouldn't put energy i think
well okay so what you're saying is like
we should just ignore it and pretend
like it's not happening
no i didn't say anything i didn't say
that once listen that's how it's coming
off to her
yeah that's not what i said once look
you can't say let's pretend like it's
not happening
because and i will put myself with you
on this we
are white passing individuals right so
we have the privilege to ignore these
issues
but the people who don't look like us
the people who look darker the people
who have
a disability the people who are out with
their partner of the same sex
they don't have the benefit of ignoring
these issues i just say one
what i didn't say ignored once you just
said we're shining too much light on it
no no no no what are you saying is that
there's everyone's talking about
problems too much
and not enough solutions if you point
out problems yeah i can find a problem
with anything right
i can find a problem with this water i
can find a problem with joe's hair i can
find a problem everywhere i'm not saying
and i never once said ignore and i never
once said not talk about it
i said we should have confidence but
here's the here's the thing about how to
solve things how to move forward so
what's your solution
i don't have a solution otherwise i'd
run the world yeah
my point is that the conversation should
be about solutions
rather than people having conversations
about problems but here's the thing
i think it's like an addict right you
have to recognize that you're an addict
before you're sure to have a solution
and for a lot of people
they live reactionary like they're
there's a lot of people that that that
just react to the world
they don't think for sure they don't
think they don't know they don't how to
quiet their mind
they're too busy like talking right so
in this case it's good to recognize
a problem to know like oh hold on like
i'm feeling this way because in a
relationship
i always do x and then they have to
recognize that sure
because most people are just living this
cyclical life where everything just
keeps reoccurring
and they're not taking the time to stop
and think yeah so i think that's really
important that there's these
different levels of consciousness where
you have to uh
first understand that there is a problem
going on
whether it's because um you come from a
traditional household and they can't
you know accept that you're thinking
differently whatever it is
your your specific problem is you have
to recognize what that is first and
foremost
i think where it goes south though is
when the blind lead the blind yeah and
then you go you're
the reason why this is your problem is
because of men or
is because of white people is because of
big groups those are so
blanket right like that's not really the
problem that's just
blame because problems come from multi
like a
ton of different reasons it's not just
one person
like oh you're the reason why you're
this way is because of trump
like not one person can cause such a
[ __ ] up
thing right so i think that's where the
problem comes is when the blind lead the
blind
and then this whole [ __ ] big-ass
group starts to form
and everyone wants to burn down one
individual or one group
yeah what you said ties into what
stacy's doing at her seminars is
self-awareness has to be step one
you're not self-aware on what your
issues are what your beliefs are and
actually critical think then you can't
move into the next step and that is
number one issue because
people will just hear what trump says on
cnn or what so-and-so says on fox and
then they're just regurgitating to the
friend
like oh yeah bart well i don't believe
in abortion and like if bart asked me
why like i got no
nothing to say because i just heard it
on [ __ ] tv yeah rather than being
self-aware enough like
well i believe this because this is who
i am yeah these are my beliefs and now i
can go forward with all right if
a problem does come up what is the
problem and what's my belief on that
issue and how can i move forward
or how can i critically think which i
think is number two is critical thinking
which no one [ __ ] does
[ __ ] no that's a skill that takes
decades
it's the secret of life yeah but i mean
the problem is
is when people have this simple solution
and blame a group for sure and then it's
my group versus your group
that's i think that's the it's only
adding to the problem and that's that's
exactly where our problems are because
then it's like oh we're the good guys
you're the bad guys or drawing a line
right like left right
yeah yeah whether you're super right or
super left or whatever you don't see
each other as different members of
family in the same group
you see it as enemy yeah you're my
[ __ ] enemy because you're against me
and then now it's okay to kill that
enemy because they're against your tribe
yeah or do whatever i need to do for
mine and mine yeah yeah
and i think that's where the climate of
the world is
becoming where it's like women against
men they're out to get you they're
they're your enemy or like the the
liberals and the [ __ ] republicans
yeah you guys will never be friends like
we should
you know that's that's people
friendships yeah
family members that's the number one
thing that they look at when they're
dating
politics i believe medical beliefs i
believe i believe it i think if you're a
[ __ ]
idiot and you think one word uh
universally
represents who you are how bad is that
then it's two idiots
dating each other and going you know
it's like it's like me like let's say
like if i if i eat meat and someone has
vegan on their dating profile and i
automatically assume all these things
that means i'm a [ __ ] idiot and if
she thinks i eat me she's a [ __ ] but
that's even better to me because that's
descriptive when you say
i'm a vegan we understand at least what
they're doing if you just say i'm
conservative
like conservative on what economical
social like there's it's such
so many [ __ ] topics are just thrown
at you when you say
i am a liberal i am a conservative
rather than if you say i'm a carnivore
like
well all right he eats meat at least we
know a specific if you just say i'm
conservative
you're literally giving out to the world
that i believe everything that this one
political
leader told me to believe yeah that's
[ __ ] idiotic yeah
and everything seems like a fanatical
religion yeah i think that's what's kind
of [ __ ] [ __ ] up
yeah dogmatic do you think it got worse
because of internet the internet because
now everyone and then the algorithm how
it just feeds you the same [ __ ] that
you're already consuming
i do think it's definitely part of
social media the internet
and money obviously rules all right
because politics are involved with money
and
what's going to get views are are these
mega
uh extreme headlines and what's then
these these kids or or people that
aren't critical thinking or know
themselves enough are just reading the
headlines
and identifying with one type of person
color sex gender whatever it might be
and when you identify with that like
all of us want to identify with
something i don't think it's just
internet and the headlines too i think
it's like the peop the consumers
actually
the ones they have partial blame too
because if they are
absorbing everything to them passively
and they're not critically looking at
every single post and headline coming up
that they're also to blame what's what i
mean they're they're only reading a
headline they're not even reading
yeah so you can't really blame the
internet or social media either because
like everything that i'm looking at at
online i always have a grain of salt
whether i agree or don't agree
i just know there's all these other
exceptions to the rule but if i blindly
look at everything i'm oh yeah this is
wrong
this group is wrong then i think that's
there to blame i have trouble listening
to like different
podcasts or like reading stuff because i
think i'm ultra critical
uh almost to a bad extent we're all
reading i'm like this motherfucker's
biased and i just throw it out
like i can't listen to this podcast i
could tell this guy's got an agenda well
everyone has some sort of bias or agenda
for your
perspective yeah everyone does yeah it
the problem becomes
when um people try to shut down other
people's perspective
and say that they're wrong for thinking
a certain way but isn't that what just
happened
in a non-confrontational way um i say
for example we're just going to use this
as an example
i say okay there's a women's seminar and
automatically everybody assumed like oh
it's anti-men why can't we go
uh i was joking but it would i do
believe that it would come off weird if
i did a men only seminar
right but is that why it's
because we've been oppressed your whole
lives right and just to make it clear
and on the record it's not an anti-man
seminar it's just a woman
uh uplifting seminar no i don't think i
don't think so i don't think mike was
saying
uh i don't think mike was saying that
you're doing anything wrong
i think what he was just saying is the
people out there
yeah are focusing way too much on the
problem and not the solution
no i give your i give your seminar
credit that you're you're going there to
people learn about themselves yeah i
don't know which i think it's number one
fix yeah i don't think he was
uh poking any holes at what you're doing
when i said i wasn't invited or i'd do a
only seminar uh it was ten percent uh
what i believe in
yeah we're only joking about the
stereotype outside
because there are there are fragile men
out there that are like
really talking about well how come women
get to have all this stuff but we can't
celebrate the guy stuff
shut the [ __ ] up dude bottom feeder
[ __ ] picasso
yeah you can do it goddamn i don't know
what that means but yeah it's the sucker
fish
the fish tank that's the fish tank on
the wall
that's [ __ ] funny why i don't know
i mean they're like the they're like the
most lowest of the most
like right now right there's this big
movement of um
women trying to build like a more sense
of confidence and place in the world and
all that stuff
which i think is great you deserve to be
here right because i think
you know just seeing my mom and
especially
traditional minority families way
different like
like they didn't go through the same
civil rights and same type of
empowerment that the women here in the
west have
so they're in they're kind of like in a
different realm it's you know even in
latin america all that stuff it's very
different
what these guys are talking about though
is toxic
feminine feminines yeah feminist stuff
or whatever any any error
it doesn't matter what the [ __ ]
category but what they're doing is
they're focusing on
the loud idiotic minority and they're
not really seeing like the majority
of what's going on here it's like
majority of women getting together
finding a place to kind of like bond and
grow each other which is very important
with society at all like we're as a
society we are getting better
does that mean we should be complacent
no but like we had slaves like 100 years
ago right like that's [ __ ] wild we've
done a lot of good things
is it is it done no we got a ways to go
to accept a lot of different humans
these things are talked about for sure
and we should talk about it
and it's it's sad and it's like like
ugly to think that these things are
still going on and it's like
like stressful and i [ __ ] get anxiety
over it but if we don't talk about them
and we pretend like they're not there
then no one is ever gonna fix anything
you know right so it's not like
for example i can put myself out there
and say i'm not here saying like [ __ ]
man and [ __ ] this and [ __ ]
i'm just saying like you're a woman
you've been through a lot let's get
together and talk about it yeah right
i don't know if what you consider is a
positive or a negative way
but it's just crazy to me like we could
even go to the racing like i am so proud
to be mexican that i have had people
tell me
why you're not proud to be an american
[ __ ] the [ __ ] i am
but like i can be proud to be both you
know like i don't have to put one down
that person sounds dumb
they do they really are but you know
there's dumb people out there
um so my point is some people need
empowerment too though
they need some stupid empowerment
seminars love attention
and you know like they just need to
identify that within themselves yeah i
mean i think
what's going on though is like let's say
there are other seminars out there like
like like yours right but
sometimes they're focused on just
blaming men
yeah and it creates toxic well there's
the opposite what's what's group called
this like guys that
i mean it stems down to this isn't what
they call themselves like guys that
can't get laid and so then they just
hate women
right um yeah these are larger groups
that have been customized people right
there
they're called the in-cells there's a
lot of they're themselves
of the internet and we use that term a
lot lightly but it is like
guys that just can't get a date or they
can't get dude friends either but they
can't get a girl to pay attention to
them
they've been rejected their whole life
they probably didn't have a mom or mom
that loved them now they hate
women yeah and they get with the passion
and that's their whole focus is how
women are this and when they suck and
they're taking the world all they do is
blame women because they can't get laid
yeah but
but if how could we solve this buddy a
little self-awareness
you understand that maybe you're [ __ ]
off focusing on the possibility well
maybe you need to work on how to
communicate with people maybe you need
to go take a goddamn acting class or
something so you learn
you know your vocab better how to be a
smooth killer like this guy and then and
then you get all the ladies
yeah focus on solutions
[Music]
[Music]
you